ANXIOUS TO SEE THIS MATCHUP.
GET THE MOMENTUM IN THEHE AT THE
HAS BEEN REUNITED.
THIS WAS A GOING
TO GET THE PUCK FROM CROSBY.
MAKES A NIFTY PLPL
RODRIGUEZ
GUENTZEL.
THIS IS HE TAKES OFF.
HE'S OUTSIDE OF
THE PENGUINS
TERRITORY. DeSMITH.
IT SEEMS LIKE THOSE
FINALLY -- YEAH, THERE'S A
CELEBRATION.
IT WASN'T GOING TO DO IT UNTIL
HE AND HE'S
RELIEVED.
YOU CAN TELL  INCREDIBLE.
FOR THE BLUE JACKETS, AND BIG P.
>> Jody: BLUE JACKETS PENALTY
KURALY'S WITH IT.
LOOKS THE GAME AND LOTS OF
ACTION HERE IN THE PAST
4-5 MINUTES.
END TO END ACTION AND
ZACH WERENSKI LEADS ALLLL BY LA.
HAD IT ROLLED OFF PENALTY.
>> Jody: JAKE BEAN IS GOING TO E
PAD OF KORPISALO AND
MATHESON JUST LEANS ON IT.
JOONAS KORPISALO THI.
MAX DOMI ACROSS ICE.
BEING AT THE POINT. COMMANDED T.
IT'S A THE KURALY
PENALTY, FIRST OF TWO AGAINST
THE BLUE JACKETS.
YOUR SCREEN.
>> Jody: BIG BLOCK. STICK BUT
HE'S GOT THE PUCK, MORE
IMPORTANTLY, THERE ARE 23
SECONDSody: HERE COMES CROSBY
WITH THE BOARDS.
>> Jeff: PITTSBURGH PENGUINS.